hey guys this is Henry from from
learning welcome back to my channel I'm
just back from a nice long run that I
did with my wife we are preparing for
our next marathon this July and now we
are ready to get some nice food so I'm
gonna eat that before I do the actual
video for today but just as a spoiler
it's going to be about visibility it's
going to be about what you need to do in
your workplace to actually stand out and
be perceived by the senior leaders and
thought leaders in the organization is
actually somebody who really adds value
to your team and your organization this
ability is a key concept that you need
to understand in order to advance in any
corporate organization of any kind so
hang in here with me it's gonna be
interesting and it's going to be very
important
so once again welcome to another coffee
break with firm learning my name is
Hamish and today we talk about
visibility visibility is really a game
changer visibility can make or break
your career so it's super crucially
important that you understand what
visibility is all about and the reason
why I chose this topic for this video is
the following
I recently thought back about a
conversation I had with some colleagues
at an internship I did at a tech
consulting company many many years ago I
was still in university dilemma
undergrad and I was working at a large
German DAX corporation it's the big blue
chip stock index in Germany and this
consulting firm was working for this
large company so we were on the client
side almost every day so I noticed that
in a period of a couple of weeks all the
colleagues were getting a bit more
nervous there was some kind of tension
in the room that didn't observe in the
earlier weeks of my internship so I
asked a bit around what is going on and
I learned that actually now it was
designation season so they had a process
where two or three times a year each
colleague got evaluated and if they
match certain criterias posed in
guarding tenure but also regarding
performance they would be designated to
the next level and then of course would
get a higher salary more benefits and so
on and this was obviously a big thing
for everybody at the company so
everybody was a bit nervous of course
trying to make the very best impression
at work at this time trying to perform
as good as they could and then I
overheard a conversation the two of the
more senior colleagues and the team head
which really made me think in this
compensation day high it was about
visibility
and what do I mean by that what happened
where they were talking about what
another client and the team was a bit
more junior and they were discussing him
and they were saying hey this guy he is
a good guy he's doing good work but he's
just not visible enough this is what
they were saying so they were doubting
whether he would make the cut and
actually get the promotion and for me
this was something completely new of
course I was very young and maybe also a
bit naive and I the way I was thinking
about the work was that well if you do a
good job at some point
this is going to be recognized and then
at some point your team lead or your
supervisor we picked you and then we
designate you and then this is how you
advance in your career right do the job
as good as you can and this will be
enough but the reality is it's not
always working like that this is far too
simplistic to really describe all these
kind of things were can happen in
especially larger corporations but at
Rus this is not very different and more
smaller sized corporations this way and
yes of course do a good job having a
good and stellar performance at the
things that you do this of course
important and will make a difference in
one way or the other how far you get in
your career I think you know doesn't
matter how much politics are going on in
a company in the end how good you do
your job will always somehow influence
your chances in terms of getting along
and doing them the next step in your
career but and this is I think a very
basic truth that is probably hard to
understand for many new joiners people
just starting out in business it is not
enough other concepts for instance
visibility is very very important and
let me give you an example how that
could play out why that might be
important so if you think about how
these designation processes work in our
companies and of course here are
differences from company to company but
in general all this works is that once
or twice every year the HR community
will meet with the business leaders of
the organization and they will ask
themself to question ok who can I can I
designate to the next level who makes
the cups to now advance to the next
position and yes of course this is
probably more like this in roads like
consulting or banking they have this
cycle of constantly being designated
every couple of years if you're good
enough maybe there's a slightly
different industry where it's more
opportunity based if there's now a road
that is opening up then people ask
themselves ok can we put in this role
but there is well you will have
evaluation cycles like this that also
work somehow in this manner right so the
HR leaders were together with the
business leaders they're having a
discussion and
Who am I going to designate and usually
how this works is somebody prepares the
case for the individual who then gets
discussed and kind of next the case if
he proposes to designate the person or
not and what the reasons are what this
person is worth why to get designated I
now think about the role of this person
right usually it's a senior leader in
the organization he will have several
more junior colleagues working for him
maybe not all of them are directly
working for himself so he needs to reach
out to maybe an in-between boss who then
has more directors Poehler or to the
person in order to understand if this
guy is a good guy or not right of this
guy's worth TASM designated so often in
these kind of situations the person
actually makes kind of a significant
part of the decision namely by making
the recommendation whether to designate
the person or not it's not even doing
that based on first-hand experience with
working with the the candidate but
rather only maybe drawing from from
hearsay drawing from conversations he
had with other people will actually give
a more or less favorable review of the
individual module so what is actually
visibility visibility is how visible you
are as the name says to the senior
leaders in organization do they know
that you will exist does somebody maybe
two levels above your boss know that you
exists does you know where your
strengths are does he really know what
you did for the organization what the
projects were that you were working on
how you did in these projects but other
initiatives might be that you were
driving and really how important you are
to the organization as a whole is this
visible to the people to whom this
matters namely the senior leaders in the
firm you're working so now put yourself
in the shoes of a person who needs to do
these kind of review processes maybe he
knows you a little bit maybe not but it
becomes obvious that how visible you are
to this person is super crucial and
super important in the specific that
certainly needs to make about what your
future is in the organization and
whether this means a designation or any
and of other review process or other
just perception that the person has
about you doesn't matter right but how
visible you are to the person clearly
makes a huge difference for you in your
career and why doing a good job might be
helpful for that might be a necessary
condition for that it's not the only
thing right and this alone for sure will
not make you visible to a person several
steps up in the letter and a flirty meet
for instance because he just might see
the performance of the team leader and
the team as a whole and notice that it
actually is going pride way but it's
very hard for him to judge just by
looking at it outside in what the
contribution of individual team members
and that he might be that even also
might need to review so is this a bit
unfair yes it is for sure it's unfair I
mean in a perfect world the only thing
that should matter is how good you do
your job how reliable you are how when
you deliver on the things you're
supposed to do this should be all that's
relevant when these things are decided
but the truth is is just not how this
works this is just not the truth just
doing a good job alone won't do it in
one sentence that is very often
described in order to really make this
graspable is the sentence perception is
reality perception is reality think
about that what really is the reality
here at least in such a business context
it's not so much what you really do I
mean you can sit at home and then talk
to your partner all the things that you
did and how great of a job you did in
home part you are for the corporation
but if the perception of everybody
around you is that actually you're not
really doing a good job and you're not
really adding value to the business then
this won't help you lie perception is
reality what you need to be good at and
what you need to become good at is the
management of the perceptions of the
people around you and yes for sure
this is politics right this is what is
going on in these large corporations and
this is also what makes these places
kind of annoying or maybe tiresome to
work in because they are full of
politics like this but the truth is also
that it's not necessarily better and
organizations in shades of gray for sure
but things like that happen everywhere
and if you want to be successful in your
job and I would say not only in your job
but in almost everything you do in life
in the end what matters is understanding
this principle of perception is reality
do a good job this is the reality but
make sure that other people have the
perception that you're actually doing
your job because if other people do not
perceive that do not have the perception
that you're doing your job then actually
doing a good job is no help for you at
all
especially in a context where you are an
employee and do not directly benefit
from the results of your work so now I
would like to give you three tangible
tips what you can do especially if you
are a new joiner if you are in a
position that you just started your work
life what you can do to actually improve
your visibility
so guys if you're getting venues so far
from this video please press the like
button and please also subscribe to the
channel here on the subscribe button
below in case you are not subscribed yet
this would mean a lot to me I have many
more content plan for the next days and
weeks are you ready three tips number
one first clearly communicate your
successes and very often we have this
mentality of maybe we are but chive we
do not want to speak out about what we
actually accomplished at work what we
actually did in the last days or weeks
because we feel that we do not want to
brag about our achievements especially
not towards your boss
where you may be even afraid that this
is perceived as arrogant or something
like that and why this is very
understandable and for sure you would be
or you would need and why this is
understandable and for sure you need to
be a bit careful to not overdo it it's
important that you let other people know
if you would get something great that is
really adding value to the business or
to your team do good things and talk
about that I think this is an important
principle don't just do good thing don't
just do good things and then not talk
about that but do good things and then
do also talk about that to your
colleagues through your boss not in a
pretentious manner but rather just
letting them know what you did in your
next team meeting your next one-on-one
with the chef just recap with them the
deliverables that you accomplished in
the last days and just make sure that
it's really clear to them what you
actually achieve what you got done in
the last days don't just keep this to
yourself and just assume that maybe over
some other ways they will kind of know
and understand what the good things and
the skills are that you have but
aggressively let them know about the
good things that you do because if you
do not advocate these things
I mean who it's supposed to do that
right maybe your colleagues say yes this
guy was really helpful in my work but I
mean come on you cannot rely on that and
again perception is reality it's not
enough that you just do it but you need
to make sure that there's also the
perception on the other side of the
table that you actually got these things
done because only then this is really
adding value for you in your career if
you if you just do this the second tip
is related to that and it's about how
you communicate
Kate your achievements to your team
colleagues but also to your supervisors
and there's a pretty natural tendency
I'd say that if you work on a team you
always talk about we write we did this
we achieved this last week we worked on
that we got that done and so on and so
forth and this is of course often fair
why you often just want to make sure
that you do not take the compliments for
something that maybe not you but your
team achieved very often this leads to
the perception that actually your
specific contribution wasn't that large
but it was rather a team effort right
everybody did something and Bs of course
you also did something but it was an
effort of the team and I think what's
important here is to always also stress
or your specific contribution to that
reside was right so yes you can talk
about what you've achieved as a team but
then also say I did this I worked on
that due to my efforts last week because
I caught somebody up last week this is
then what happened and this is not about
you making something up right this is
not about something else or somebody
else did it and then you just claimed
that you did it this is of course not at
all what I'm recommending you to do but
the many things that you did do the many
things where you really did take
ownership and did make an effort to
really bring that success to the team
make a transparent that this actually
was your contribution that you actually
did that and I think this is an incident
tip that not only applies to how you
communicate but also in for instance
written applications so even job
interviews if you know supposed to
describe about what your chiefed in the
past here again is very common for
people to say we did this read a dead
and so on and then for you as an
interviewer if you know I'll try to put
yourself in the shoes of the other guy
it's really hard to understand hey but
but this guy Heinrich what did he really
achieve what can he do for us right so
always also stress not only what the
team result was but what your specific
contribution to that result has been
just to make that visible and also
create the impression that us a person
really add value to the team my third
tip is to pick up initiative and
organize some things
beyond your daily day-to-day job and and
what do I mean by that often in a team
or in an organization there are things
where you can volunteer or where you can
take the lead and do something which
might not directly be expected from you
but it might not be that your TV comes
to you and tells you Henryk if this is
what I want you to do right but still
just adds value to the team and if only
to the spirit and kind of the team
feeling as a whole and some examples it
could be that you for instance organize
a team event
you just organize the event for your
team where then you organize everything
and then the team goes maybe to an
off-site and evening or some Reds just
to have a good time and then hopefully
everybody comes back in the office next
day and it feels like more bonded a
better team to everybody this could be
one example or maybe you organize some
kind of sports event in your office or
you take ownership of any kind of other
initiative that is going on so these are
the things where this is likely going
beyond your job this is not directly
expected from you but you should
ownership mutual initiative you show
that you want to contribute beyond of
what is necessarily directly expected
from you and by that this will be
visible right of you know you have 40
minute and and he would see that now the
team has gone to the team event with or
without him he were very quickly picked
up who that also organized that and who
made this effort for better team
experience for everybody and of course
your main roads your main
responsibilities will always be more
important don't do these things if they
put you in danger of actually delivering
against the things that you're really
supposed to do and that are really
expected from you because if you do that
then it doesn't really matter if you
organize the great team event of your
actual job is not done right so
prioritize correctly but very often you
will find yourself having a bit of spare
time having a bit of extra capacity that
you could invest in these kind of things
and then it is super value but if you do
that if you take initiative take
leadership and then do something good
for the organization this will be
recognized and this for sure will put
you on the list of these more senior
leaders and then make you more visible
so let's recap visibility is super
important and it means how visible you
are to the senior leaders in your
organization do they know that you exist
do they know what you are doing for the
team do they know why you really add
value to the organization as a whole
perception is reality doesn't matter
it's not enough if you do just a good
job you need to make sure that other
people understand and perceive that you
do a good job otherwise it's just not
worth a lot so make sure that this
perception is there make sure that you
are visible I hope if you follow these
tips that this will help you and if you
really enjoyed this please click the
like button and subscribe to this
channel below this would really mean a
lot to me if you just subscribe to my
channel I have many more content pieces
lined up for in the next days or weeks
so I would love to keep you here on the
channel thank you this is Jaime from
from learning